I'm sure we have all heard about
fortnight here or there but recently
fortnight has actually been losing steam
over the past couple of months
over half the interest in fourtner has
disappeared so here's the top 5 reasons
that fortnight is failing and if you
want to hear about what's going to
happen to fortnight make sure stick
around till the end
[Music]
welcome to Hari Saudis Fortner actually
dates back a lot longer than you would
think all the way back to December of
2011 this is when Cliff Bleszinski from
Epic Games formally announced fortnight
at Spike Video Game Awards the idea was
pitched just a couple of months ago and
everything came together very quickly
and here they were with the trailer for
tonight was originally actually going to
be a paid to play game only but when
tension bought a huge stake in Epic
Games in 2012 everything would change
they strongly insisted on offering a
free-to-play experience as this would
cover so many more people but that same
year Cliff Bleszinski and designer Rob
Ferguson would leave Epic Games and this
would really slow down the development
of fortnight throughout 2013 development
was really focused on Gears of War
judgment and fortnight was really pushed
on the dragon and a couple of months
into the year they begin testing
eventually in 2014 Epic Games would
reveal the storyline of fortnight's save
the world throughout 2015 and 2016
fortnight would go relatively quiet as
testing continued in their background
there would be some press appearances
here and there but nothing really too
significant but by 2017 fortnight was in
high gear and Epic Games was really
focusing on his release starting in June
of 2017 they would offer paid early
access and the key would officially
launch in July of 2017 but again at this
point they only offered save the world
which was not free it's not till
September of 2017 that Epic Games would
reveal fortnight Battle Royale
which is heavily inspired by pub G this
was initially revealed as a separate
mode but would soon become free-to-play
it took a while for them to get some
momentum but once they got some they
skyrocketed and this is how the
fortnight that we know today was created
but if you look at Google Trends
over half the interest for fortnight's
disappeared over the past couple of
months so what can explain this first of
all it's really nice that for panas free
to play but the accessories are grossly
overpriced aside from the occasional
challenges that offers games for free
the only way to really get skins is to
pay real money all of these skins are
organized into four distinct levels the
first of which being green or uncommon
which costs 800 B bucks
the second is blue or rare which costs
1200 v bucks and then you have purple or
epic for 1500 v bucks and then finally
you have the top-of-the-line gold are
legendary for 2000 v bucks
how many v bucks you'd get per dollar
really depends on how many v bucks you
buy the more you buy that better value
it is but for all intensive purposes you
get about a hundred v bucks per dollar
this means that the cheapest the on
common skin costs eight dollars and if
you buy three gold skins you've already
paid the price of a full retail game
skins should definitely not start at a
price over five dollars and the thing is
epic games is consistently launching new
skins so it is pretty much impossible to
keep up now I think we all understand
that Fortnight needs to make money
somehow to compensate for all the
development fees and server charges but
for the amount of traffic that they get
and how popular this game really is they
could charge a lot less and this will
allow them to retain a lot more
customers more people would actually try
to buy all of the skins and they'll be
more invested in the game plus to make
things even worse skins don't offer any
advantage or they're not designed to at
least this gives no incentive for people
to buy skins other than just to look
cooler
people are more likely to continue to
play game if they actually paid for it
or are in some way invested in it but
when the game is free in the overpriced
accesories don't even offer anything is
very unlikely that people get invested
with money in the game as a result most
people use the default skin and there's
nothing new refreshing about the game
and this has led to a much lower
retention rate especially among casual
gamers and the thing is the game can
easily get pretty repetitive the concept
is pretty good you'll work with the team
or alone and try to be the last man
or team standing but the progression is
pretty slow and often still or often
just going around houses looting at the
beginning and if you die early you
really never get involved in any real
action oftentimes it's just simple
mindless playing until a storm I really
close this in and this makes the first
part of every single game pretty boring
and eventually people lose interest
there's really no new missions or
objective to complete in the game now
Epic Games was really trying to combat
this by offering new modes like get away
in hosting events and of course they've
changed the map every single season as
well and all of these are very green
quite effective but all of these can
only go so far at the same time when the
beginning of any single game is so
repetitive and boring it's only a matter
of time before people move on and
another huge problem that Fortner has
that other games don't have is server
issues this is mainly caused by the high
popularity of the game and less popular
games really don't struggle from this
and the intense pressure that servers
are under really become evident
especially in major events but at the
same time it's been not worth it for a
fortnight to buy new servers as these
errors and crashes only occur in huge
events the problem is is that these
couple of things are really what keep
the game refreshing and new for many
players and when they can't even
participate in these is raped by
frustrating and this again built on the
point that fortnight gets repetitive it
is also really hard for free-to-play
players to advance in the game the
battle passes a system of progression
that fortnight battle royale offers with
this you can earn in-game rewards
progress and level up but the thing is
you have to buy it with your currency
and it costs 950 B books yes always
costed this amount it may go down in the
future but in July of 29 still cost 950
B books so as of now you basically have
to pay $10 and this is almost like a
consistent fee for every single season
there's been nine seasons so far so
that's 90 dollars that's much more than
a retail game of course you can get it
for free by saying the books that you
get from the free pass but the rewards
for the free pass is very scarce and not
nearly as much as the battle
and the thing is people who are not
willing to pay for the Battle pass
aren't gonna spend all the time that it
takes to actually get the battle pass
for free as a result with a no real
incentive to continue playing most of
these people quit even if you're really
serious about getting the battle pass it
will take you most of the season to get
it if that you have to devote a lot of
time to the game and this game time is
not fun you're not playing with her
buddies having a great time instead
you're continuously grinding on
challenges trying to save ebooks and
this completely defeats the purpose of a
game you're better off doing an extra
shift at work and then paying for the
battle pass you would make a lot more
money than what the battle pass would
require and you're saving a lot of time
as well and the thing is it's probably
just as enjoyable as grinding out the
battle pass for free the high difficulty
of advancing in the game for free really
turns a lot of people from playing the
game at all
as it becomes more of a tour than actual
fun and finally the main reason for this
success and eventual failure of
fortnight is casual gamers fortnight has
really had a lot of trouble balancing
casual and hardcore gamers and making
them both happy you don't really see
free-to-play games on PCs or serious
consoles thus these games are dominated
by hardcore gamers and free-to-play
mobile games that clash of clans and
clash royale are dominated by casual
gamers but when you try to criss cross
casual and hardcore gamers you get a
split demographic that's looking for two
vastly different things first there is a
casual gamer who's simply trying to have
fun they're not too serious about
winning and they're just messing around
with their friends and this really
annoys serious gamers who are trying to
get better and win at the game and then
you have the other type of casual gamer
who is actually trying to get better but
these people get absolutely dominated by
serious gamers who have vast experience
from other games like pub G and this
really makes it frustrating for both
sides and in the end all of them end up
leaving all the hardcore gamers flocked
back to her favorite games where people
actually take it seriously the casual
gamer who were just playing for fun
eventually get bored and the casual
players who are actually trying to get
better will eventually quit in
frustration
and this really hinders affordance
ability to build a long-term fan base
and this has left fortnight in a very
weird position today they still have
tens of millions of players who play the
game every single day but this is not
necessarily a demographic that they
really want right now you only have two
real demographics that play the game you
have the top players and youtubers who
make a lot of money from playing the
game and that's their main incentive and
then you have the casual gamer who is
thirsty to win and this is finally their
chance and there's nothing wrong with
doing either of those but the problem is
that none of these people really enjoy
playing the game and play the game to
play the game and that's not what
Fortnite needs and these two
demographics also don't create that much
revenue for fournette either the top
players and most youtubers are really
focused on being the best and they don't
care about buying the newest skins and a
casual players who haven't won yet are
mostly kids from the age 8 to 12 and it
don't really have that much buying power
and the thing is the kids will leave
right after they get bored of winning
because they're not in it for the
experience they're just in it to win it
now that might be good for a competition
but that's not good for building a loyal
fanbase and the second that fortnight
stopped sponsoring huge tournaments all
the top players and eSports players will
flock the scene and that's the problem
they may still have a lot of people who
play the game but none of them are
really enjoying the game they're not
building a fanbase like Call of Duty or
Infinity Blade where people actually
play the game because they like it and
that's a type of demographic that keeps
games going for several decades this
demographic that fortnight has will
eventually die out and that's where
fortnight stands today and why they are
quickly losing popularity fortnight
truly revolutionized the gaming industry
by offering a free-to-play game that was
also quite serious this garnered
worldwide attention and allowed for data
obtained previously unimaginable Heights
but this also led to a slew of issues
like over pricing in game purchases
which made it very hard for free-to-play
gamers to move ahead on top of this the
repetitiveness and class routing
hardcore and casual gamers really
blocked fortnight from developing a true
fan base in
the end fortnight won't be the next huge
gaming franchise that lasts for several
decades like Call of Duty or Mario but
I'm sure that epic games is more than
satisfied with the fortnight success and
they definitely should be as Fortin has
really made its mark but that's all I
have for you guys on fortnight
make sure comment down below what
company you would like me to cover next
also if you guys like this video then
make sure drop a like and consider
subscribing if you like to see more
videos just like this one but well then
I'm worried I'll see you guys on the
next one